ciao mariners e benvenuti in un
nuovissimo
video questo è un video molto importante
per me e avrete già capito il motivo in
questi anni sotto i miei video in
tantissimi mi avete scritto maria mi
piacerebbe vederti in un film perché non
fai l'attrice ecco io ho sempre sognato
di poter recitare in un film e tanti di
voi non sapranno che da piccola ho avuto
qualche esperienza nel mondo del cinema
prima come comparsa poi come piccolo
ruolo e infine era arrivata diciamo 32
lette la mia prima occasione importante
the crow stata scelta per essere la
protagonista di un film voi vi
chiederete cuore film ecco non ve lo
posso dire che quel film non è mai
uscito quel film purtroppo per vari
motivi che vi sto a spiegare non l'hanno
girato e quindi è stato veramente brutto
e stata una grande delusione per mero
ero piccola ma non tantissimo voto 12 12
13 anni dopo questa delusione ho pensato
che magari il destino ha voluto così
quindi magari un segno è però diciamo
che ho continuato a coltivare questa
passione della recitazione tant'è che
come tutti sapete ho aperto un canale
youtube proprio per
far prima di tutto divertire persone ma
anche per mostrare diciamo le mie
passioni quindi video in cui cantavo e
video in cui recitava le scenette
comiche che conoscerete tutti e qui
arriviamo al punto perché per me è molto
emozionante fare proprio un video dopo
quasi sette anni dall'apertura di questo
canale in cui posso dire finalmente che
ce l'ho fatta e li potrete vedere al
cinema e la cosa fantastica è che sono
stata notata proprio grazie ai miei
video qui visti tanti di voi avranno già
visto il trailer mi state scrivendo che
occhio ma se tu nel film si sono io
faccio parte del cast del film i titoli
delle donne diretto da lillo greg ed
eros puglielli oltre ovviamente a lillo
e greg che conoscerete tutti ci sono
degli altri attoroni corrado guzzanti il
mostro sacro della comicità italiana
ilaria spada che di una bellezza di una
procura pazzesca poi c'è valerio
lunghini francesco arca daniela piperno
insomma un cast pazzesco e io sono
onorata di aver potuto condividere
un set insieme a loro nel film
interpreto quanità che è una ragazza
colombiana all'interno del film avrà
un'evoluzione
abbastanza drastica però non posso
spoilerarvi nulla per adesso in questo
video volevo anche raccontarvi come però
stata contattata come avvenuto il tutto
allora era una domenica stavo
passeggiando insieme a salvatore salvo
il mio fidanzato e un certo punto arriva
una mail alla mia nero ovviamente un
ufficiale mi scrivono i brand eccetera
eccetera per chi fa il mio lavoro è
abbastanza risaputo che di domenica
solitamente non ti contatta nessuno
quindi liperini arriva questa mail da
una casting director dicendomi bull e
vorrei parlare appunto di un progetto
cinematografico in cui vorrei
coinvolgere marin amore che marina
facesse il provino io ho detto proprio
testuali parole guardato salvo e faccio
a me sarà una bufala per scrupolo
abbiamo risposto e tipo dopo dieci
minuti eravamo al telefono
effettivamente con questa casting
director che tra l'altro saluto
tantissimo praticamente questa ragazza
mi aveva appunto nottata su instagram
particolare per le mie parodie sapete
quello che faccio delle professioni hip
hop insomma per i miei video che ha
deciso di contattarmi per propormi
questa parte innanzitutto quando mi
hanno detto che il film di lillo e greg
figuratevi io li segue da tantissimi
anni amo la commedia italiana quindi ero
già subito esaltata ma la cosa che mi ha
scioccato e che la parte effettivamente
sembrava cucita addosso né mi sembrava
quasi di sognare però nonostante questo
appunto che è stato detto devi fare dei
provini ci sono altre ragazze quindi
detto maria countdown
per adesso non vota non gasati anche
perché reduce dalla delusione di quando
i ragazzi alto figurati qua sarà
un'altra tranvata impatto up registro il
primo sex tape un video in cui ero in
casa mia dove appunto recitavo alcuni
stralci delle copione che mi erano stati
inviati cosa succede ho inviato questo
sex tape e dopo circa una settimana sono
stata chiamata perché avevo passato
questa prima selezione e dovevo andare a
fare il codino
talenti a roma con i registi quindi con
eros lillo e greg questa è una foto
scattata proprio pochi minuti prima di
entrare a fare il provino ero con saldo
e avevo la stessa lo stesso topino che
ho utilizzato nel sex tape perchè ha
detto mi ha portato fortuna passato la
prima selezione
magari è un topino fortunato infatti non
l'ho più messo dopo da da quella volta
non lo colpì messo perché ormai fa parte
dei siti sacri
della mia correttissima circa una
settimana dopo noi torniamo a milano
anzi ma settimana dopo forse due giorni
dopo era passato pochissimo tempo
infatti io pensavo ci volesse più tempo
con la risposta io ero al supermercato
ance punto mi scrive salvo corri a casa
per tutti io cosa ho pensato le peggio
cose perché ovviamente me l'ha detto
non me lo voleva dire è però dovrà dire
di a casa che dobbiamo parlare e arrivo
a casa mi guarda mi fa allora mi ha
chiamato la casting director
purtroppo anche stavolta non sei stata
fortunata e a lillo non sei piaciuta ma
me l'ha detto seriamente
cose di casa come nonché per mio
piangere e fogli guarda scoppia a ridere
i fatti hanno presa io come mentre sa
piangere erano in lacrime ed è stato
bellissimo già abbassare da cuomo di
nuovo no
un'emozione pazzesca
mi hanno presa primo giorno di riprese
24 giugno è stato un mix di emozioni
pazzesco ovviamente il film è girato a
roma quindi avevo il mio albergo a roma
ho fatto mille foto al mio camerino che
il mio primo camerino quindi perché ho
fatto le foto di qualsiasi angolo ero
presa benissimo abbiamo girato la scena
finale che vedete è appunto alla fine
del film quindi il mio primo giorno
l'ultima scena
molto particolare come scena che poi
scoprirete perché mi sono trovata
davvero benissimo con tutti con il cast
con la troupe è da subito lillo mi è
piaciuto tantissimo in primis come
persona perché veramente una persona
di una bontà e di una spontaneità
pazzesca oltre ovviamente essere un
grande artista grande comico e mi ha
fatto sentire subito a mio agio anche
nelle scene con lui c'è il proprio mi
sentivo a casa
e sarò da dire mai così non sa che fosse
il mio primo giorno sul set brevemente
come funzionavano le mie giornate sul
set mi svegliavo circa alle cinque o sei
del mattino quando giravamo tipo fino
alle 6 invece se stavano fino a sera un
po dopo poco ha comunque mi svegliavo
abbastanza presto questa tra l'altro vi
faccio vedere era la vista dalla stanza
del mio tenera estate il rumore dei
gabbiani il sole che sorge risvegliamo
appunto all'alba mi venivano a prendere
e andavamo appunto al campo base dopo
venivo truccata e pettinata
una volta finito trucco parrucco tornava
nel mio camerino a no aspetta prima di
far qualsiasi cosa arrivato campo base
tampone questo non ci fosse un domani
tutti i giorni vagamente
trucco e parrucco camerino trovo in un
camino ripassavo la parte e poi vengo
chiamato appunto per andare sul set
ovviamente troesch e dall'altra c'erano
i vari ritocchi poi cosa succedeva
pranzo prezzo ovviamente mangiavo 10 20
minuti di riposino e poi si tornava a
girare una volta finito di girare mi
veniva accompagnato in hotel cena e
crollavo dalla stanchezza però era quel
crollare soddisfatto cosa mi ha lasciato
questa esperienza sicuramente mi ha
fatto capire che quello che vorrei fare
che è una cosa che amo fare e che vorrei
averla qualità di continuare a fare per
migliorare e per mettermi alla prova con
ruoli e kim diversi sul set risorse di
da totalmente a casa a mio agio sfortune
son sentita viva che è una cosa
veramente bella vi sentite stessa senti
che stai facendo qualcosa che ti fa
stare bene e penso che sia fondamentale
soprattutto se riguarda appunto la sfera
lavorativa a fare qualcosa che ami e pop
sicuramente è stato anche dovuto al
fatto che appunto si è creata una
bellissima sintonia con tutto il cast e
vi assicuro che non è una cosa che
succede spesso mi hanno garantito anche
gli stessi attori quindi davvero non
avrei potuto chiedere di meglio da
questa esperienza tra l'altro tra
l'altro chi mi segue sa benissimo che io
non amo giorno del mio compleanno anzi
forse lo detesto e per la prima volta
quest'anno cioè scorso anno la scorsa
estate abbia finito le riprese è stato
la prima volta in cui mio compleanno
l'ho vissuto bene perché perché ero sul
set era l'ultimo giorno di riprese finto
stata anche la festa di fine riprese e
cioè non l'ho vissuta quella giornata
come il mio compleanno ho vissuta come
una festa in generale un fine di una
bellissima esperienza e quindi niente è
stato bellissimo
qui vedete le foto festeggiare la fine
delle riprese è il mio compleanno
insieme alla troupe e insieme a il cast
di questo film di questo mio primo film
ci tenevo a fare questo video
innanzitutto per raccontarvi quello che
c'è stato dietro a questa esperienza
quello che ho provato e sono con te
disse perché già in tanti mi state
appunto scrivendo che non vedete l'ora
che esca il film che siete contenti per
me e soprattutto che me lo merito per me
non c'è cosa più importante perché
assolutamente non vorrei deluderli non
voglio deludervi e spero che insomma di
piazza questo film e siate contenti per
me quindi mi raccomando mi raccomando
non abbandonate ma i vostri sogni non
mettetevi limiti e nonostante le
delusioni che ci saranno perché ci
saranno continuate a lottare per i
vostri sogni perché anche quando
penserete che sarà che è che è troppo
tardi che è destino che non dobbiate
fare quella cosa vi assicuro che
succederà qualcosa che vi farà ricredere
ci vediamo al cinema dal 14 aprile con
gli idoli delle donne mi raccomando
andatelo a vedere fatte ovviamente per
me e fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate si
rifà ciuto invito a diventare i vostri
messaggi e di sapere insomma come vi è
sembrato vi mando un bacione enorme
grazie mille per seguirmi da così tanto
tempo e per sostenermi in tutti nei
piccoli grandi traguardi ciao mariners
adoro